[Music]
on this saturday night a second day of
protests in ottawa
the multiple messages behind the
demonstrations at the national war
memorial they're attaching veterans to
try and have legitimacy as police
prepare to fend off another potential
occupation
resisting a russian advance he said that
situation is horrible the russians are
bombing as hostile every day growing
pleas for the safe evacuation of a steel
plant shielding ukrainians and severe
storm threat across the u.s this is
andover kansas right now oh my gosh a
destructive tornado rips through kansas
as separate weather systems leave 40
million people under new weather
warnings
global national reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
downtown ottawa is once again the scene
of mass protests a series of rallies are
expected to clog the capitol through the
weekend many attendees took part in the
weeks-long occupation of ottawa in
february police have made several
arrests and say they will not let
protesters paralyze the city dan spector
has our top story from ottawa tonight
many who felt abandoned by police during
the convoy occupation see this
demonstration as a test for authorities
and residents we've spoken to feel
officers are taking this one a lot more
seriously
they promised it would be loud and they
delivered
hundreds of motorcycles rumbling through
ottawa as people lined the streets to
cheer them on the ride carefully
monitored by police who are restricting
vehicles from entering certain areas
biker's just one of several groups with
different messages descending on the
city for a weekend of protest honoring
the veterans
straight forward
honoring the veterans
the bikers had links to a saturday
morning rally at the national war
memorial speakers angry about the
cenotaph being fenced in during the
convoy protests in the winter that
lasted more than three weeks
[Music]
they held a wreath-laying ceremony in
the presence of several canadian forces
veterans it was shameful what what the
government did when they put those
fences around that like that should
never ever happen again but not all
veterans were on board some taking part
in a counter protest every conspiracy
every nutter every grift asking for
money they're attaching veterans to try
and have legitimacy
some at the veterans rally praised the
occupation earlier this year many of
them having taken part the convoy in
ottawa was a glimmer of hope i'm worried
that we're going to end up a communist
country
a few hundred people from another group
gathered for an anti-vaccine
anti-mandate rally on parliament hill
there were some heated exchanges between
protesters and fed up ottawa residents
we don't want this around here
send them all home after facing strong
criticism police are being assertive as
they try to avoid a repeat of the convoy
seven arrests were made at a friday
night rally at least two people were
taken into custody on saturday including
this man reportedly breaking bail
conditions after being arrested here in
february officers are handing out
hundreds of tickets and towing dozens of
vehicles we wanted to make sure that our
communities and our neighborhoods are
protected at the same time we want to
make sure that people have the right to
protest the weekend is set to conclude
with a church service sunday morning
many ottawa residents hoping this time
the demonstrators leave once it's over
nitu
dan specter in ottawa thanks dan
ukrainian forces are fighting to hold
back a russian advance from the east it
comes as the united nations works to
broker a civilian evacuation from the
city of mariupol there are reports 25
people have been taken out from below a
steel plant but nearly one thousand
civilians remain here's david aiken now
and a warning some may find these images
disturbing
in mariupol medics are desperate to save
their patients
we ask we beg this doctor says to be
given the chance to save the lives of
injured fighters by evacuating them
two thousand soldiers and as many as one
thousand civilians are holed up here in
the besieged azov stall steel plant
the wives of some of mariupol's
ukrainian defenders had been evacuated
to safety in italy where they now plead
for the evacuation of their husbands we
think that mariupol
have to have a chance and not
only civils we come here to
rescue
live soldiers too
because
but russia's foreign minister blames the
ukrainians for the humanitarian crisis
there is only one problem
humanitarian creditors which are being
announced on a daily basis
[Music]
by the ukrainian
ultra nationals
but there is no evidence that is true in
fact russian aircraft were bombing the
steel plant again saturday russia also
sent missiles towards odessa in
southwestern ukraine on the black sea
coast ukrainian officials say a missile
hit the airport and has put a runway out
of commission in the northeast in and
around harkeev ukrainian forces attacked
russians this video provided by the
ukrainian military is said to show
ukrainian forces destroying russian
military assets but russia launched at
least three strikes on the industrial
complex in harkev no desert injuries
were reported and on the west block this
sunday we're going to talk a lot more
about the crisis in ukraine with retired
us general philip breedlove breedlove is
a former nato supreme allied commander
he is also an enthusiastic supporter of
the idea of finland and sweden joining
nato and he has some ideas about what
the west including canada can do beyond
sanctions to get vladimir putin to
change his behavior nitsu
david aiken in ottawa thanks
in her first official trip to washington
as defense minister anita anand visited
her u.s counterpart at the pentagon the
two discussed their allyship and each
country's response to the russian attack
our abigail beeman sat down with anad
where the minister laid out canada's
next steps to support ukraine
canada's defense minister tells global
news more armored vehicles could be sent
to ukraine in addition to the eight
announced this week as the government
figures out how to spend the half a
billion dollars committed to ukrainian
military aid in the budget so there will
be a strategy behind the spending of the
500 million dollars
which may well include additional
vehicles anita onan says she talks to
ukraine's defense minister about their
needs almost daily but she won't say
where canadian soldiers are training
ukrainians on the m7777 howitzers or
just how many canada sent
firstly because of security concerns but
secondly we are still engaged with our
allies and there is a potential
to continue to collaborate on the
provision of additional
weaponry onan spent time with secretary
lloyd austin this week not just at the
pentagon but at a meeting of nato allies
in germany austin had strong words about
russia we want to see russia
weakened to the degree that it can't do
the kinds of things that
it has done in invading ukraine neither
canada's prime minister nor defense
minister has matched that language this
week we also heard russia accuse nato
allies of being engaged in a proxy war
i'm wondering what you think about that
and and if you're worried that that
comments such as the one about weakening
russia could further antagonize putin
again i'm not overly concerned with the
rhetoric coming out of the kremlin i am
concerned with ensuring that we do
whatever we can
to militarily equip ukraine to fight and
win this war so busy with that i do not
have plans to visit ukraine of course in
their first meeting at the pentagon
anand and lloyd discussed more than
ukraine norad modernization has long
been promised by canada on and would
only say a plan is coming this spring
abigail beeman global news washington
the senior bishop from the church of
england is in saskatchewan this weekend
on a trip billed as an opportunity to
repent and atone for the anglican
church's role in canada's residential
school system nathaniel dove reports and
a warning some may find this story
distressing
welcome bishop welcome the archbishop of
canterbury has come to meet survivors of
canada's residential school system
including dennis sanderson
the abuse the sexual abuse
the many things that happened to me that
school
it hurts sanderson was forced to attend
the residential school at gordon's
reserve in saskatchewan
last week the chief there said they had
discovered 14 possible grave sites
the facility just one of nearly three
dozen canadian schools run by the
anglican church between 1820 and 1969.
sanderson says justin welby needs to
know the damage the church of england
inflicted upon children many of whom
still carry that trauma i don't know i
didn't know how to
handle
a child
i didn't know how to
nurture a child sanderson wants an
apology
for the anglican church to say that i'm
sorry for the roman catholic church to
say i'm sorry
i accept that the archbishop is here now
to listen
they're meeting at james smith cree
nation
in a room surrounded by symbols of
empire
tradition and reminders of the horrors
of the past the archbishop's words and
acknowledgement
in
ignorance
needing to hear
and in shame
needing
to signify that change and respect
those on whom such terrible
injustices were committed
welby says it's impossible to know all
the stories but says he wants to become
deeply aware of his ignorance
he didn't apologize but we'll continue
meeting with survivors and visit a large
gathering on sunday
where he will make an official statement
nathaniel dove global news
there is a 24-hour crisis line available
for anyone experiencing pain or distress
as a result of their or a loved one's
residential school experience the number
is toll-free it is 1-800-721-0066
the department of national defense says
it's investigating an incident on the
campus of kingston's royal military
college that left four officer cadets
dead friday morning tonight we're
learning more about those lost in the
crash sean o'shea reports
it's one of canada's most prestigious
universities where military and academia
come together in an elite 1200 student
school it's a shock it's
it's just hard to hard to process right
now and a day after the deaths of four
cadets at the royal military college the
mayor of the city of kingston ontario
describes a great loss you talk about
four students that were you know just
about to graduate you know and having
you know great careers ahead of them
it's just it's just so sad mayor brian
patterson is also an economics professor
at rmc he taught two of the four who
died the truck they were traveling in
left a campus roadway and sank in the
waters where lake ontario meets the
saint lawrence river around two in the
morning on friday four at a time
under such circumstances
it's tough the military college will
discuss details of what happened now the
subject of an investigation by the
department of national defense we need
to let this investigation run its course
the college wouldn't even confirm
whether the men were traveling in a
military or civilian vehicle what
appeared to be a toyota tundra officials
also instructed staff and students not
to speak to anyone in the media the
students were identified as officer
cadet jack hogarth officer cadet andre
honshu officer cadet broden murphy and
officer cadet andreas salek their deaths
came on the second anniversary of the
deaths of four other rmc graduates among
six who died in the crash of stalker 2-2
a canadian forces cyclone helicopter
that went down off the coast of greece
it was the largest single loss of life
for the canadian military in a decade so
on a day where we're remembering a very
somber moment here we are starting yet
another grief period local residents
agree heartbreaking it's a it's a tough
story you know rmc has been a part of
our community for
for
forever very sad for kingston so i think
we're all feeling that a community with
strong ties to canada's military
mourning those who died here sean o'shea
global news kingston ontario
coming up growing concerns with more
rain set to hit flood-battered regions
of manitoba and the weekend weather
warnings across the u.s after a
devastating tornado strikes kansas
highway 75 south of winnipeg is closed
today as flooding hits southern manitoba
rainfall warnings are in place for much
of the region with up to 44 millimeters
expected to fall over the next day
dozens of evacuation notices were issued
last night as residents try to protect
their homes from flooding with water
pumps and sandbags this is the third
major storm in as many weeks
millions of americans are under a severe
storm threat right now while several
weather systems bring damaging winds
hail and tornadoes to the central plains
that's in addition to the wildfires in
the west some of which are still burning
out of control and are moving
dangerously close to a string of
mountain villages jennifer johnson
reports
look at that
a massive tornado touching down near
harrington kansas as more than 150
destructive storms tore through
america's midwest this is andover kansas
right now
oh my gosh oh my gosh another twister
hit andover kansas look at that look at
the bottom of it destroying homes
businesses and cars fire officials say
close to 1 000 structures were in the
tornado's path some families had about
30 seconds warning to take shelter it
was a shock to be honest with you
i've been close but never that close the
devastation is so widespread the town
has appealed to state officials for aid
to help families rebuild unfortunately
we've been through this before and
it'll be years
that we'll be recovering from this we'll
get through this this wicked weather
system is now moving east severe storms
are possible from pennsylvania to
tennessee sunday
meanwhile another severe weather system
is kicking up gusty winds from colorado
to texas to new mexico states already
battling wildfires because of extreme
drought fueled by high winds
hundreds of people have had to evacuate
their homes some in a matter of minutes
still you know in the back of my head
that there's an active fire up there
there was about 10 crews that went by
this morning to you know check the fire
lines
there are already hundreds of wildfires
burning in several states in america's
southwest a very early start to the
wildfire season officials are hoping to
be spared lightning strikes this weekend
that could spark even more fires
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up the bc company converting
conventional cars buses and entire
fleets to evs
interest in electric vehicles is higher
than ever amid record gas prices and
climate change concerns but supply chain
hindered deliveries and rising gas
prices have pushed many to choose
electric conversion turning vintage gas
guzzlers into energy efficient rides
erin mcarthur shows us how one bc
company is cashing in on the trend with
big plans to expand
[Music]
out with the old
and in with the
well take a look what's in here is an
oversized golf cart i refer to this as a
60 pound turkey the 60 pound turkey is
what powers this 1976 porsche 912
the battery powered ev now puts out 50
percent more power with only 20 moving
parts
the conversion the brainchild of dean
knighter the founder of rise ev i can go
out and buy a tesla but it's not going
to make like this has way more appeal
that i've done something right i've kept
an old classic car on the road i'm
greener cleaner
no emissions
and it just makes logical sense the
company with a shop in east vancouver is
focusing right now on converting classic
sports cars
there's a kit that will fit porsche
models spanning 20 years but the
conversion possibilities are endless
lady called me with a 76 volkswagen bug
but then i had a gentleman come in here
with us i can't remember what year it
was but it was an old rolls royce i've
had guys bring in tractors and rvs
the cost of conversion isn't cheap it is
pretty fast
north of 50 thousand dollars depending
on range and power
but the future of the company will be
converting commercial fleets the price
tag of a retrofit school bus
about half what a new electric model
would cost there's so many rules and
regulations with canada that's hindering
me from doing the buses where i could go
to seattle oregon and idaho right now
and sell those buses all day long the
1976
912 e was the pace car at last week's
sun run
zero emissions
and plenty of turned heads
aaron macarthur global news
next a scrappy bc artist turns trash
into treasure
[Music]
just one day before she was to be
inducted into the country music hall of
fame naomi judd has died her daughters
winona and ashley announced they lost
their mother to mental illness along
with winona naomi performed in the band
the judge scoring 14 number one songs in
a career that spanned three decades the
group was scheduled to play a 10-date
farewell tour across the u.s this fall
naomi was 76 years old
a british columbia man is using his
unique skills to turn old scraps of
metal into beautiful works of art as jay
durant reports he's proving one person's
trash really is another's treasure
part-time artist james howells is still
learning the tricks of welding it was
his cousin who gave him a crash course
and some sound advice
don't electrocute yourself
howells needed to find a new creative
outlet and stumbled across an idea along
some old tracks near his place north of
pemberton
and that's how the metal artist got his
start
turning old discarded rail spikes into
unique figures it's trash we should pick
it up and and turn it into something
chainsaw chain now he's collecting all
kinds of scraps for his projects iron
pipe from gas fitting oh barbecue
rotisserie bike pigs from my son's bmx
bike don't tell them i took them turning
them into choppers and lobsters horse
heads and some real heavy metal
oh wait do you see my gibson inside the
gibson's better this is art that's good
for the environment this is heavy metal
and it just goes it just gets
it's absorbed into the ground an old
clothesline
[Music]
thing you can see their sockets there's
gas fittings
there's nuts this is a rotor from a
lawnmower and i recycle propane tanks i
made a really cool 1964 volkswagen bus
out of a 30 pound propane tank
it's at the point now where neighbors
are leaving piles on his porch for him
to work with
people clean out their shed oh james
would like this handful of nuts and
bolts this is a piece off of a router
you can see his chain and bicycle chain
that's this holster yeah if it ever the
house ever burns down
my art will still be there
everything is available for sale even
the prized horse head it's become a good
little side business turning trash into
treasures for his customers it liked
seeing something being made out of
nothing
and and it really
people really appreciated that
jay durant global news
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm nitu garcia tonight
we leave you with scenes from the
opening weekend of the richmond night
market in bc after two years of
cancellations and pandemic restrictions
it's back at full capacity thank you for
watching have a great night
[Music]